-Please, welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody!
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today the CDC
made a huge announcement
about wearing masks.
Watch this.
-The CDC now says that
vaccinated Americans
generally do not need
to wear masks outside
as long as they're
not in a large gathering.
-When people heard that,
people in the street started
flashing their mouths
like it was Mardi Gras.
Like, whoo!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got to be honest, I'm gonna
miss wearing a mask.
The adult acne
made me feel young.
[ Laughter ]
On the bright side,
now we can finally stop
weirdly opening our eyes
to greet people on the street.
Like --
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
The CDC updated its guidance on
outdoor masking
for both vaccinated
and unvaccinated people.
And they even released
this helpful chart.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I like to think
the sketch artist
at the CDC is like,
"I'll tell you, I can do hair,
ears, eyes, and mouth.
I just don't do noses."
[ Laughter ]
I just don't --
It's just not my thing."
The two most important things
about a -- Ah.
"I'll do it for cheap,
I'll do it for cheap.
I just don't do them."
[ Laughter ]
The chart ranks activities
from safest to less safe
to least safe.
It's the same chart people use
when deciding between
Delta, United,
and Spirit Airlines.
[ Laughter ]
Well, it's a big week
for President Biden.
Tomorrow he delivers his first
joint address to Congress.
Yep, everyone is looking forward
to hearing Biden speak.
Then, at the last minute,
they're going to call on
Anthony Hopkins instead.
[ Laughter ]
It's always interesting to watch
a presidential address.
Half the crowd cheers,
half the crowd sits in silence.
It's like a throwback
to Harry and Meghan's wedding,
don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Biden's address will be
on all of the major networks.
Of course, on Telemundo, Biden
will be dubbed in Spanish,
and on Fox News,
he'll be dubbed by a demon.
-[ Speaking demonic ]
[ Applause ]
-Some tech news --
After a long wait,
Apple rolled out a new privacy
feature that requires apps
like Facebook to ask permission
before tracking
the activity on your iPhone.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
So now you can relax at home
in total privacy.
-Yes, total privacy.
Ha-ha-ha.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, after years of infringing
on our privacy, Apple is like,
"We're against collecting
your data, starting now."
[ Laughter ]
Apple also introduced
new emojis,
including face exhaling
and face in clouds.
Take a look.
[ Laughter ]
Even the eggplant emoji is like,
"Come on, we all know what this
is supposed to be."
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-"We gonna play this game?
We gonna play this game?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. Come on.
I saw that Guinness
just debuted a new beer
with Nitro Cold Brew Coffee
in it.
Check it out.
Yeah. It's the perfect gift for
the sluggish drunk in your life.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great product if you want
your heart to feel like it's
napping and skydiving
at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
It should be fun walking around
the office with a can of that.
Like, [Slurred] "9:00 a.m.,
time for another pick-me-up."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] That's right,
Guinness and coffee.
Irish people call that
baby formula.
[ Laughter ]
And another unlikely pairing --
Goldfish has teamed up
with Frank's RedHot for new
limited-edition spicy crackers.
Here's a photo.
[ Audience oohs ]
And normally I make a joke about
these kind of food mash-ups,
but I'm going to level with you.
This one sounds spectacular.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Right? When it comes to
recent innovations,
I put the COVID vaccine at 1,
this at 1A.
[ Laughter ]
To some it sounds weird,
but it's still better than
Gerber Sriracha.
[ Laughter ]
Welcome back -- Baby hot ones!
-Come on.
-Hey, some good news
for Dunkin' Donuts fans.
They just announced
they're adding
coconut milk to the menu.
Yep, they'll keep it
on the table
between the cream
and the ashtray.
[ Laughter ]
And if you order it, legally
they're allowed
to make fun of you.
"I got a large iced coffee
for Prince Brandon,
who's too good for cows.
That's Brandon,
B as in bee-atch!"
[ Laughter ]
And finally some news
from overseas.
I read that next month
a high-end apartment complex
in London is opening up
a see-through pool
that sits 115 feet high.
Look at this thing.
-Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
-It's perfect 'cause when I
think sunny rooftop pools,
I think London.
[ Laughter ]
You know someone's last words
are gonna be, "Cannonball!"
Hey, Quest, welcome back
and congratulations, buddy.
-Hey, thank you.
-That was fantastic.
Questlove.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The musical director
for the Academy Awards!
-Yes.
[ Crowd cheers ]
-Dude, you looked great.
You sounded great.
What was it like?
Were you -- Was it weird?
Were you nervous?
-It was fun.
I mean, that's the first time
that I have been out anywhere
since the last Oscars, so...
-Wow.
-You know.
But, no, it was fun.
It was a little party, you know.
-Yeah.
-We had fun.
-But that opening where
Regina grabbed the Oscar,
you were doing that?
-Oh, man, that was so hard.
We had to perfectly time --
-Right?
I was sweating for you, dude.
I was like, "Oh, my gosh."
-Yeah, I didn't think
she was gonna make it.
But I kept extending it
and looking at the end marking,
yeah.
-And then the biggest moment
of the night,
besides Daniel Kaluuya,
was Glenn Close.
-Yeah.
-Doing "Da Butt."
-Who knew that she knew
"Da Butt"?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I did not know.
But she's fun.
-Everyone asked,
"Was that scripted?"
Really, we didn't prepare her.
She just -- We told her
something was gonna happen,
but she didn't know.
-Yeah, you never know what
someone's gonna do.
Of course, she so is game.
-Yeah.
-She's so much fun.
Remember when she came on
the show and we had a contest,
how many baby carrots
can we fit in our mouths?
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "What is going on?"
She was just so game.
She was like,
"Let's do it, why not?"
-That's how I knew
she was game for this.
-Yeah, I love --
Anyways, it was great, buddy.
Congratulations.
-Thank you, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is big.
The Census Bureau just released
their findings for 2020.
And according to the data,
there are --
these are some
fun facts for you --
331 million people living in
the United States.
-Ooh.
-Pretty interesting.
In fact, there were a lot of
surprising results
from the Census here.
-Really?
-Yeah. Check out some of these.
First up, 489,000 people
are named Jeff,
but for reasons no one can
explain, spelled G-E-O-F-F.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-Geoff.
-Yeah.
-489,000, that's a lot.
-Look at this -- 11 million
people think the Quaker Oats guy
is a Founding Father.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-11?
-I might be one of them.
-Yeah.
-Check out this next result --
7.5 million people don't know
if reindeer are real
and are afraid to ask.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But they answered
the census though.
-Yeah, of course.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, they're afraid to ask.
-That's a specific question.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Look at this -- 3.5 million
people believe Mount Rushmore
is a natural rock formation
that just happens
to look like four presidents.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's insane.
-Crazy.
-That's impossible.
-More than Geoff.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Up next, 20 million people
can't describe a goatee
without using their hands.
[ Laughter ]
"It's like a --
That."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-How about this one here?
750,000 people think Elon Musk
is a cologne
they sell at Walgreens.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I remember wearing it
in high school.
-That was Drakkar Noir.
-Yeah.
-And finally, 165 million people
"literally can't even" anymore.
I literally can't even.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I learned a lot. Stick around.